so we have this rectangle right over
here and we're told that the length of a
b is equal to one so that's labeled
right over there a b is equal to one and
then they tell us that b e and b d
trisect angle abc
so b e
and bd
trisect angle
abc so trisect means dividing it into
three
three equal angles so that means that
this angle is equal to this angle is
equal to that angle
and what they want us to figure out is
what is the perimeter of triangle bed
triangle b
e d so it's kind of this middle triangle
in the rectangle right over here so
first it seems like a pretty hard
problem because you're like well what is
the width of this rectangle how can i
even start on this they've only given
one side here they've actually given us
a lot of information given that we do
know that this is a rectangle we have
four sides and then we have four angles
and there the sides are all parallel to
each other and that the angles are all
90 degrees which is more than enough
information to know that this is
definitely a rectangle and so one thing
we do know is that opposite sides of a
rectangle are the same length so if this
side is 1 then this side right over
there is also one the other thing we
know is that this angle is trisected now
we know what the measure of this angle
is it was a right angle it was a 90
degree angle so if it's divided into
three equal parts that tells us that
this angle right over here is 30 degrees
and then this angle right over here is
30 degrees and then we see that we're
dealing with a couple of 30 60 90
triangles this one is 30
90 so this other side right over here
needs to be 60 degrees so that side
right over there needs to be 60 degrees
this triangle right over here you have
30 you have 90 so this one has to be 60
degrees they have to add up to 180 30 60
90 triangle 30 60 90 triangle and you
can also figure out the measures of this
triangle although it's not going to be a
right triangle but knowing what we know
about 30 60 90 triangles if we just have
one side of them we can actually figure
out the other sides so for example
here we have the shortest side we have
the side opposite the 30 degree side
now whatever if the 30 degree side is 1
then the 60 degree side is going to be
square to 3 times that so this length
right over here is going to be square to
3 and that's pretty useful because we
now just figured out the length of the
entire base of this rectangle right over
there and we just used our knowledge of
30 60 90 triangles if you see if that
was a little bit mysterious how i came
up with that i encourage you to watch
that video we know that 30 60 90
triangles so we know that 30 60
90 triangles their sides are in the
ratio of one to square root of three
to two
so if this is one this is a third degree
side this is going to be square root of
three times that and then the hypotenuse
right over here is going to be 2 times
that so this length right over here is
going to be 2 times
the side right over here so 2 times 1 is
just 2. so that's pretty interesting
let's see if we can do something similar
with this side right over here
here the one is not the side opposite
the 30 degree side here the one is the
side opposite the 60 degree side
this is the one opposite the 60 degree
side so once again if we multiply this
side times square root of 3 we should
get this side right over here this is
the 60 remember this one so right over
here this one this is the 6 degree side
so this is going to have to be this has
to be one square root of threes of this
side let me write this down one over the
square root of three and the whole
reason i the way i was able to get this
is well whatever this side if i multiply
it by the square root of three i should
get this side right over here i should
get the 60 degree side this side
opposite the 60 degree angle or if i
take the 6 degree side if i divide it by
the square root of 3 i should get the
shortest side the 30 degree side so if i
start with the 60 degree side divide by
the square root of 3 i get that right
over there and then the hypotenuse is
always going to be twice the size twice
the length of the side opposite the 30
degree angle so this is the side
opposite the third degree angle the
hypotenuse is always twice that so this
is the side opposite the 30 degree angle
the hypotenuse is going to be twice that
it is going to be 2
over the square root of 3. so we're
doing pretty good we have to figure out
the perimeter of this inner triangle
right over here we already figured out
one length is 2. we figure out another
length is 2 squares of 3 and then we all
we have to really figure out is what ed
is and we can do that because we know
that a d is going to be the same thing
as bc
we know that this entire length because
we're dealing with a rectangle is the
square root of 3 this entire length if
that entire length of square root of 3
if this part this ae is 1 over the
square root of 3
then this length right over here e d is
going to be square root of 3 minus 1
over the square root of 3. that length
minus that length right over there and
now to find the perimeter is pretty
straightforward we just have to add
these things up and simplify it so it's
going to be
so let me write this perimeter of
triangle
b e d
is equal to this is short for perimeter
i just didn't feel like writing the
whole word is equal to 2 over the square
root of 3
plus
square root 3
minus 1 over the square root of 3 minus
1 over the square root of 3
plus 2
and now this just boils down to
simplifying radicals you could take a
calculator out and get some type of
decimal approximation for it let's see
if we have 2 squares of 3 minus 1 square
root of 3 that'll leave us with 1
one over the square root of three
two divided two squared of thirds i
should say two over square root of three
minus one over the square root of three
is one over the square root of three and
then you have plus
the square root of three plus two and
let's see i can rationalize this if i
multiply the numerator and denominator
by the square root of 3 this gives me
the square root of 3 over 3
plus the square root of 3
which is i could rewrite that as
plus 3 square roots of three over three
right i just multiplied this times three
over three
plus
plus two and so this gives us this is
the drum roll part now so one square to
three plus three square roots of three
and all of that over 3 gives us 4
square roots of 3
over 3
plus 2 or you could put the 2 first some
people like to write the the
non-irrational part before the
irrational part but we're done we
figured out the perimeter we figured out
the perimeter of this inner triangle bed
right there